then this one you see how I move out of
the way Peter Pan a certain speed right
we were not doing that one
I'm not turning him and I'm not moving
out of the way so here you go slow
because I think you'll feel it more if
you go slow so here's me and here's me
deliver it okay so I'm not going to do
that
but I have moving yarns I think easy but
you can see how light that is right same
thing it's not here but I am moving him
you see well we're pulling back you see
but here what you're going to notice is
that if my arm is slipping I can't do it
so my
I can't do it it's cutting into you it's
not anything so but I'm going to be
stuck wherever you're touching there's
going to be a friction that I generate
by how much I'm pushing you have to cut
off like you see that but you have to
get off right here okay and so wherever
we're touching then I will always have
that so I'm gonna have you focus in on
not pushing it and not pulling off not
slipping so you're here so here we are
I'm gonna be stuck here I'm not gonna
have my arm go like that I keep the
extension at that zero point and then
I'm controlling him you see so he is
turning but not by those other two
mechanisms okay not by me getting out of
the way he does some crazy
or me going here and going like that I
have this zero
[Music]
we just exaggerating the extend these of
movement in the throwing but right there
I got it but no close give do you
understand exactly but extending the
drill
I'm Luthor that is he hops okay go stop
stop stop I lose it
[Music]
you see now you put it off you just shot
in the fall
[Music]
here we go I have and it's not this okay
oh he's leaning on me you see right here
I have the right to keep that well if
she falls
[Music]
no slight leave that friction where it
is
[Music]
do your job that's it okay
not here this noise that are you
generate the friction that you need okay
so not plus not negative right there so
I don't slider out on them and I don't
break contact and I don't push them
through you understand that hey Charlie
yeah cuz they start to fall away so go
ahead and reject and work the other
skill so remember we started here boom
right whoa now we're just going here
so I'm gonna use all three points you
see her at fist right here so I don't
want to go like that
I use all three points to get the angle
that I want and then my body will
project through so you can see how I did
it
[Music]
that's not here like I did again you're
gonna do it here
no I don't have a heavy hand I have a
very light man right it's very light but
we're stuck she's not if she don't don't
push into me you see I put my follow her
so it's not in your normal okay where
the room is like keeping contact and
there there's that's not what's
happening
I'm keeping contact with her I keep
contact with her so see where this arm
is I'm not making it go like that I
stuck to it you guys see that they're
warm
I move it with that zero friction
wrong-o this is the same thing I'm doing
here on that position on the initial
position warm it's not this it's not get
out of the way she falls there and it's
not blue kid right doing that crap I'm
I'm moving her
[Music]
you